thank you
[Music]
all right do you guys remember a while
ago we had done an article about a
prisoner or a couple prisoners that were
uh under some sort of cruel and unusual
torture punishment in the U.S because
they were forced to listen to Baby Shark
on repeat oh yeah yeah that is pretty
cool that is that is it's pretty [ __ ]
up right well the uh inmate one of the
inmates in the US who's uh who has
accused his jailers of torture and
alleged that he was made to listen to
The Children's Song Baby Shark on a
never-ending Loop has been found dead in
his cell whoa but did he die from the
song that's what the optos he said
that's my baby shark dude
yeah they killed that [ __ ] his
name is John Bosco no way was found
unresponsive in his cell at
approximately 3 50 a.m on September 11th
at Oklahoma County Detention Center
according to press release I said no
wait because there's a school named John
Bosco and oh I know that's it it's all
boys school yeah Dante's cousin
so uh correction officers tried to save
the 48 year old's life and continued
resuscitation attempts until emergency
responders arrived at the scene
paramedics continue the efforts to
resuscitate The Prisoner but he was
pronounced dead shortly after 406 a.m
dude he had wound up in prison following
a drug a drug trafficking plane but the
crazy part is that he was in the midst
of a lawsuit against the county that
Drew International headlines in 2020. do
you think it's a mysterious play dude
mysterious death they killed him the 48
year old claimed back that during a
previous stint of incarceration he and
three other inmates were tortured by now
former jail employees Gregory Cornell
Butler Jr and Christian Charles miles
the two former jail guards allegedly
forced the four men to listen to the
irritating earworm of a children's song
baby shark on a seemingly never-ending
Loop for hours
the men were made to stand with their
hands cuffed behind them to a wall
during the alleged incidents in November
and December 2019.
the men were in the process of suing
Oklahoma County Commissioners Sheriff
Tommy Johnson III the jail trust and the
two former jailers at the time mid boss
goes death so lawyers representing the
prison inmates described the incidents
as torture events the three officers
were charged with misdemeanor counts of
Cruelty to a prisoner and conspiracy and
basically his uh main trial was in one
week
and then he just found
he was just so no cause yet no method
not yet you know what what's crazy is
that some things can be a torture
technique but it can also be a Mr Beast
video
should we make a video about baby sharks
no it's like no it's like I watched
[ __ ]
you know I watched Sesame Street for
three days straight without stopping or
like it'll be a challenge like like I
listen to yeah baby shark for two days
without sleeping
or last person to stop listening to baby
shark wins a million bucks yeah yeah
you win money I I got into a thing sort
of similar is I forgot what we were
betting on but my high school friends we
had some kind of bet and I lost and My
Punishment was for a month straight I
had to have the same single CD in my car
of Justin Timberlake's like I love you
for one month 30 days straight that you
have to listen to it yeah so every time
I drove it would go back to that song on
re and you couldn't listen to the radio
no I wasn't allowed to listen to
anything else and it happened how would
they regulate that because I saw them
all the time back then also they sat in
your car yeah and they would just be
dying laughing and then so they would
torture themselves by also listening
I know every bit of that song
God keep going so if you hear it playing
at like a wedding or a club or whatever
bro I can be the 10 piece orchestra
playing that song does it make you feel
like oh yeah it brings you back to just
uh 2001 Honda Civic same [ __ ] song
over and over 30 days straight yeah what
was the bet I don't even remember but I
I you remember the song because that
that took place of the [ __ ] memories
like now whenever I hear that song I'm
like oh God I just hear the sound system
of my car I can't believe you held up to
it I mean I'm a man of Honor you know
you are a man but it is torture to list
to be subjected to the same [ __ ] even
if it's a good song like that's a great
song
a great song not anymore though this is
uh quite the uh incident because like as
you cruel and unusual as it is we all
remember it is enough to talk about
something so [ __ ] unique it's like
this uh culture defining [ __ ] kid
song that had like billions upon
billions of plays becomes worldwide
phenomenon and social media kind of
[ __ ] dance thing like it's really
like unique they use it for torture and
then literally uh the boss was lawyer
Cameron's spritling or whatever uh said
that he found the circumstances of the
48 year old's death disturbing and
called for all evidence to be preserved
immediately as the investigation unfolds
because he says I'm really bothered by
this one of the baby shark victims
that's funny to say baby shark victims
is conveniently dead within three days
of his arrival at the jail how does that
happen hey that that means that nowadays
they have a statistic that Rivals actual
baby shark deaths with baby shark the
song deaths yeah you have to clarify
yeah the songs probably kill more people
for sure
it's up one it was driving him nuts so
he like either slammed his head against
the wall or maybe he would be like ran
well at this point they had already
stopped because it's already been like
worldwide national it could be like an
assassination or something they had
already uh filed a lawsuit against those
people and they were already like set
forth they're gonna say that he killed
himself because
they have not determined the cause of
death they haven't thought of it yet
they haven't thought they're working on
it I love it this year yeah because
literally
um the trial was due a couple days ago
but the victim was so we got murked
before the trial three days before the
trial they were suing to not play the
song they were suing for uh unusual
torture base they were suing the jailers
yeah cruel and unusual punishment yeah
but then they were gonna sue the song no
not the song I think the song was also a
victim in this got it
they didn't have rights to play it that
many times either that or the song
became even more viral because a bunch
of Institutions didn't incarceration
buildings around the world were like
this is a great idea so he started
playing it everywhere that is it is
pretty it's effective though I mean look
at they do that for like uh on the
outsides of certain buildings when they
don't want homeless people oh they play
classical music yeah they'll like put
[ __ ] on repeat they'll make a pinging
noise or they'll have like a high
frequency like hum so you just get I
can't [ __ ] sleep here outside of Rite
Aid wow the city does that no no private
businesses McDonald's just do that like
some Walmarts do that yeah a lot of
writing so even homeless people don't
like [ __ ] repetitive sounds yeah dude
even they have good even homeless people
don't love no because you know what do
you think of like the definition of like
homeless people or like the Trope it's
someone that's super down on their luck
you know they're like at the the last
straw or whatever so you're thinking
like
like there's they they're unbeatable you
know everything that's going on in their
mind it sucks so they should be able to
deal with anything but then even with
like assault they play Baby Shark [ __ ]
this
dude I still got standards I gotta go
somewhere else yeah I still got luxuries
in life I need to enjoying it could be
the nice comfiest Cletus Corridor but if
baby shark is playing [ __ ] [ __ ] it dude
but baby shark is getting the residual
checks though yeah they're getting paid
right I mean they couldn't be more paid
though baby shark that's true because a
million of those views came from the
jail can we see how many views baby
shark has I bet you the creator of the
baby shark I have like a billion dollars
there's no way I think they're in the
tens of billions now tens of billions
like how much they made no no just about
views oh uh let's see they've got I mean
anything kids YouTube yeah
repetitive [ __ ] do taika have a baby
shark face or was he did he did have it
when he was you guys want to kill
yourself no I didn't like it that much
kids YouTube views are not even
comparable to anything yeah because
they'll be like again again again I'm
sure that there's more taika's actually
not like too kid-like yeah like
I think the first video there's other
videos that have like a 1 billion 658
million there's like other videos of the
same [ __ ] and there's a new baby every
day that just found out yeah yeah yeah
um
don't give a [ __ ] if you tell them it's
played out yeah what is this
no and that YouTube channel yeah the
YouTube channel to uploaded video has
like 60 million subscribers so it's not
just like how many hits does that video
have it's like how many new followers
babies be subscribing oh yeah children
be [ __ ] subscribing with that
notification bell too dude because they
could listen to the same [ __ ] for like
two three years straight like it's the
first time they ever heard it I think
they got in some other bangers though
who's the group that made baby shark is
there is there an artist name the
yeah it's it's estimated that from
that's that video alone the
entertainment site has made 120 million
dollars oh that's a lot less than I
thought yeah for one video it's not I
feel like they're [ __ ] lying I feel
like they made more they just don't want
if they're Asian they don't want to
report the true number for tax yeah I
wonder how much they like sold baby
shark merchandise or something oh right
I'm sure they are licensed it and redid
baby shark and other in other languages
can you imagine this person that wrote
the song is like dude I'm a better
songwriter than Michael Jackson
arguably no yeah it that's the case
Quincy Jones me I don't know
and it is it is South Korea wow Korea
freaking there you go baby shark game
yeah dude top of the charts but when you
guys listen to a song that is good you
don't repeat it listen to it that day
like if I do I do sometimes yeah yeah
also it's like 10 times that day I'm
redigested over and over like a weirdo
but then if it's not good anymore like
after that day you're like ew well you
gotta let it wear off and then you
re-love it again yeah yeah give some
time I have a friend who listened to it
and and then he saves it for the weekend
oh that's cool to Hype them up like to
have the effect yeah yeah that's cool
that's a good effect I never know that
people because then his weekend's gonna
hit like he's gonna feel good yeah but I
don't have the discipline I want 20
times what was the last song you heard
that you played like 20 times in a row
and you were like obsessed with probably
it's an album It's called The Cool train
quartet is like elevator song it's like
dude coal train oh yeah cool tray oh
cool train oh it's a new version not
cold not cold that Coltrane the jazz
musician that plays saxophone Johnny
cool I don't know it's just called Cole
or coach so is it like
[Music]
damn I would have never thought this was
Jason Cheney like sometimes house it
kind of makes sense sometimes Country
Chicken Fries a good one who's your
favorite country band I just know that
song
and I and I repeat to listen to this
does it go like this
[ __ ] all right [ __ ] me
[Music]